i'm current davina reading for suriel
vazquez
hyrule warriors age of calamity
occasionally lets you take control of a
divine beast
it's a moment that should carry some
weight for zelda fans the beasts are
colossal machines crucial to the events
of the legend of zelda
breath of the wild and while they're
cumbersome to control the levels in
which you play as them
effectively communicate their
destructive power if you've played
breath of the wild
these moments take on pretentious air
the power fantasy of using lasers
bursts of lightning and volleys of magma
to level out mountains and rack up
thousands of bokoblin
moblin and luzolfo's kills is undercut
when you remember how the people who are
using them
can't fully control them and that these
tools of destruction will turn on their
masters when they're needed most
and destroy them the sense of impending
doom is what i
came to age of calamity for but that's
where it blunders hardest
it constantly encourages you to set
aside that feeling of dread avoid coming
to terms with the consequences of its
apocalyptic
premise and instead just kill a bunch of
baddies and think the divine beasts
are cool doing that is fun for a while
but it couldn't stop me from being
enormously let down by that choice
you stand a chance
things start well enough mostly thanks
to how age of calamity infuses the
long-running
muso formula with breath of the wild's
look and feel
mowing down crowds of bokoblins and
lizolfos is simple enough
but larger enemies like maublins and
high knoxes
require real effort to take down dodging
their attacks at the right time lets you
fire off a flurry rush attack one of the
cooler maneuvers in breath of the wild
the original hyrule warriors sub weapons
are replaced by four runes
remote bombs magnesis stasis and cryonus
and they're integrated into combat well
stasis freezes enemies in place
and launches them based on how hard you
hit them while they're frozen
while magnesis absorbs nearby metal
weapons and throws them back at their
owners
some attacks from larger enemies prompt
you to counter them with runes
staggering them and leaving them open to
attack that along with magic rods that
rely on an elemental counter system
give you plenty of options in combat
every member of the playable cast has a
distinct mechanic or trick at their
disposal too
and they help keep things interesting
[Music]
maybe the biggest game changer though is
how all the fighting is structured as
someone who adores breath of the wild i
got a huge kick out of aj calamity's
interface
and that aesthetic actually adds a
meaningful layer to that experience
you spent a lot of time looking at a map
of hyrule with mainline missions side
quests
upgrades and shops dotted all around it
getting access to a new shop may be as
simple as gathering supplies and
missions and checking off an icon on the
map but it's contextualized as securing
a trade route so the shop owners can
properly do business with other towns
with short descriptions of what happens
after you complete the task it's a small
but fantastic touch
that gets across the scope of the
warrior fighting and how
hyrule cared for its people as it faced
its end
as the map gets cluttered with icons and
the story starts approaching the major
story beats from breath of the wild
age of calamity explores some of its
history's more poignant threads
zelda's journey to uncovering her
potential how that purpose drives her
father to push her toward her destiny at
the cost of everything else
and how much of a burden that kind of
responsibility puts on someone
is told well seeing the champions in
their heyday is fun too
even if we know where their stories are
headed all these threads converge when
things start to turn
dire hyrule's hubris and thinking it
could repurpose technology it didn't
understand begins to destroy it
that sense of doom approaches but in its
most critical moment
age of calamity refuses to look its
expectations in the eye
and blinks without treading into
spoilers i found the last act profoundly
disappointing the way it explores the
most impactful moments in breath of the
wild
story subverts and repudiates much of
what made
breath of the wild so resonant for a
game meant to give that story context
it's a fatal misstep it doesn't help by
this point the other parts of the game
start to wear out their welcome
the new layers of combat are nice but
you end up seeing most of the enemies
you're going to fight throughout your
entire playtime early on
with later bosses being buffed up
versions of earlier ones
after playing the game for so long their
tails become simple prompts
missions get so easy they're tedious and
side missions are grind
it's also harder to forgive the camera
and frame rate issues which become more
pronounced
as you head into more interior areas and
produce more on-screen effects that slow
things down
despite how much i'd invested in this
version of hyrule and the nagging
feeling of leaving things unchecked i
stopped taking on side missions
stopped helping people build up my rule
and prepare for the calamity i had
started out completely on board with
seeing age of calamity's story through
being with the citizens of hyrule until
the bitter end
and just killing some baddies by the end
i was doing these tasks more
out of obligation than anything else
it's strange to think of a bungled story
leaving me so lukewarm on a zelda game
even if it is a spin-off but paying off
its premise is the burden a prequel to
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
is tasked with
the main reason i dove into age of
calamity is because i love its world and
history it tries to remember
so for a game to retread them and
proclaim to have something new to say
when it's inspiration's most striking
moments come from what it leaves unsaid
is a big ask
but my problem with age of calamity
isn't that it fails to live up to that
responsibility
it's that it doesn't even try it doesn't
even have the courage
to see things through